- go umbrellas and Merry Christmas I
don't know Liza than the nerdiest
whatever anyway welcome to them Nisha
Christmas special a lot of you bros
asked for a Christmas special and I
looked everywhere for one and no one
were making it so I asked good old
flames to make one for me I helped them
out a little bit I'm not gonna spoil
what I did you'll see eventually I did
this picture to him yeah I did that and
anyway I don't know any credit for this
he really put a lot of work in this to
this in a short time so welcome to Anna
Nisha Chris I actually wrote this
Christmas special you are lost in the
North Pole how the hell that how the
hell that happened we'll never know
whoever wrote this is a [ __ ] but what
we do know that a certain someone is
trying to steal Christmas and a place
Santa Claus will you be the savior of
Christmas but I did anyway I'm gonna
leave the download link in description
if you both want to try and play this
mod after I played of course I'll look
it's Christmas oh yeah I've ever seen
Christmas Emily you shall be far look
Owen it has like a snowy effect when you
walk that's kind of cool alright oh no I
am in the North Pole oh I am lost how
the hell that I haven't in the North
Pole hey this is awesome
Wow hey Chris it's like well yeah I like
yes i'm theshia christmas better we're
gonna have like a photo showing up over
we didn't know how to do it
I mean we failed still awesome alright
hello strange this is
I thought it was gonna stop maybe when I
pick up the knife that
[Music]
all right the null containers Angus can
read it hello stranger
this is one of Santa's helpers you
notice your outside Oh
he notices I didn't ask for you to be
brought in for comfort but you were too
heavy so instead we gave you the
necessary equipment to get to send a
squad but please be worried
Santa's wife is around and she's very
angry baking again we are still see
later we are sorry that we cannot bring
you inside yet that's kind of a bad
that's kind of mean but but please watch
out for all the sort of things that
sounds is why I have left an awesome
event some random things popping up has
been confirmed all right that sounds
like Santa's house all right let's go
inside Santa's house Jesus Christ I'm so
excited to say this oh it's Christmas
hey maybe it's like I don't know I'll
par with off-loaded when it's Christmas
in Sweden i but this days I don't trust
teleporting presents I have Christmas
tree that's awesome but I don't dress
this all right it's a present for me
okay [ __ ] dis happen
all right that's always a Christmas song
awesome
ah it's the follow the gospel I have
married a guy look at me I'm wearing a
Christmas Oh Christmas cane to the sauce
merry freaking Christmas fitted do you
like that supplies Jesus guys all right
we need to come together get you dissin
oh-oh this desk welcome to my workshop
stranger advice please do look around me
and my wife would be delighted to meet
you
our last I have to finish making these
precedence Christmas is a busy time of
year that guys but guys something like a
freaking [ __ ] wait what Wow
hey double Stefanik what look away Jesus
that was me by the way in case you
couldn't tell I did some other what most
I think I need all the voice I think
some will say I don't know it's kind of
AA data but a naked guys what buddy
why are they always naked make enough
sense why can't they covered up like
normal people look at me so is this like
take me here day I'd want wipe out all
right
it's Christmas how we are sped it up hey
I like this random sucks everywhere
Jesus Christ
Hey more random sighs hi I can't get
over how awesome you look Stefani yes
big a oh sorry
what are you doing fu a pump a pump I'm
so frigging haha yeah it's Christmas
well oh yeah pity
I'm sure pump I'm sure excited by could
merry freaking Christmas everyone
I don't want to see I want to do the
stairs slide because it's Christmas
alright I'm too fat
alright actually works all right let's
see what more adventures in this
Christmas place it's kind of creepy
Mouse Jesus Christ I don't like this
very much
hey I like the hey hey don't go anywhere
spawn Wow alright I have to say goodbye
but find Santa Claus and let's get out
of here I like Vinny alright Stephano
I'll do it for you
man I hope that spawn again it was
awesome alright I'm sorry no I am kind
of comics hey there you are
hey what the [ __ ] this is everywhere
I love spitting of course I am here hey
I love your candy cane or whatever it's
awesome
hey presents for me I love present
presence in amnesia that's awesome hey
Alice else yeah this is for me it's fun
I mean I I bounced hey did you see that
I can bounce on presents let's do that
let's try that I can half-life on you do
this can you do that that would be
awesome
okay hey
I had my I want that one stop playing
around pity
stop playing it's not funny yes it is
okay
you like my head of course I like your
head it's awesome
you're like my bell I don't actually I
already have a beard no one noticed that
Santa Claus speaking out here ah all
right I guess this is Santa's workshop
there yes damn is handsome Jesus Christ
he's handsome like he's even smoking a
pipe I don't even have a pipe well it's
my pipe this sub will soon look how much
oil I have say oh how did I do that
Jesus guys why would you always throw me
clearly what the [ __ ] oh man yeah you
finally covered up at least teleporting
I don't know is it that big it's
impossible
hey I'm traveling through his not I
don't feel comfortable doing that pity
please knock it off but you like it Jes
guys stop there oh no Pig it was hairy
would have been have an erection all
right okay so this was like the workshop
of the elves I've assumed let's continue
forward and let's find Santa Claus
okay hello anyone here
ah got them out hello alright hello
what's this I see something underneath
that bookshelf could it be a pastor
Perry oh no no no oh no is this yeah oh
no I thought we were friends
I was no sorry penny I'm sorry it wasn't
my developer he was right I got no I
don't want to skip it I don't want to do
it oh I thought we were friends
I thought you were a bro it's grass man
why did god [ __ ] belly let's go I'm
sorry pity I hope this doesn't ruin our
friendship
I just wanna say Merry Christmas to all
the brows out there and now Ambrose -
even though you don't deserve it but how
much the sheriff or I love y'all again
I'm so sorry
jaysus Kyle this is why you can't dress
chair spinning I hope you learned your
lesson
god [ __ ] damnit God hey no no we're
not leaving you behind
oh no oh good good I don't want to lose
since the fauna in a bad spot
hey pear though I thought you're doing
put me down immediately you are oh there
we go there's a lever I know where
there's gonna be something yeah sliding
bookshelf
alright let's go that I did I even
though I don't cut it actually out out I
want to shake this room up for a
sexually it's locked
alright it's got pity stop wasting your
lives sorry
look at my joy I have one two three like
I'll be fine don't worry about the liner
alright
stop making weird spin the wheels move
it's really inventive here no one knows
what I'm talking about during the
livestream I will stuck it everyone
always say why don't you guys stream so
we can tell you what to do and people
were coming up with the most ridiculous
suggesting like push the cow or and then
so on a lot of bros said like spin the
wheel and I was like fine I'll spin the
wheel and then I spend the [ __ ] wheel
and nothing had been obvious save it so
here we go again spinning the wheel for
you bro spin the wheel pootie I guess
he's gonna people that you bros are
still accommodating Yin you're so
freaking strong control sometimes
hey present a lot of Prayer now why are
you Taliban our I didn't think something
what up get me out of here Pat a quick I
am stuck in his crotch I don't like that
that was horrible why would they do that
hey I'm bouncing oh man I don't know how
he did this but it's awesome
Wow okay let's focus pity
let's focus maybe we have to find a key
or something here so many presents I
just wish I could open it I bet this one
has a long just saying it could be all
right let's continue far away what is
there now justice flying Rock
I don't trust flying rocks don't don't
behaving on if the map isn't perfect he
really had dinner I didn't really didn't
give him much hey this is like a trap
I told him to add this but I didn't
remember what it's called I still don't
remember what it's called but it's
pretty cool eh yeah today all right
sweet Santa Claus you're so crazy with
that bass where are you dog Jesus Christ
they are talking to Santa Claus I do not
approve of this where did your hat go
Stefano it looks better this way yeah
you have to go here alright let's go
ahead okay that's all ha
now where's my hot pocket all sound that
you're so crazy Jesus Christ and that
seems like a fat awesome good do it good
really I have a sorrowful pity
now why would I like the position he
listen I know I'm so I'm such a [ __ ]
it was obvious I mean you're walking ah
I never learn I never [ __ ] learn boss
I knew it why would he put bells in it's
got some story we know I hate bow oh oh
no corridors but we didn't decide we
decided not to make it like just related
to me even though I oh no it has to
follow a tit but everyone loves the fun
right but this is flying blood out of
nowhere
I don't trust flying blood out of
nowhere it's fun oh can you read this
one of course I am spanner I am one of
Santa's helpers I don't know why we have
to make Diaries though okay that was
very interesting meeting where are all
the sons helper I don't understand I
love oh no I don't trust this oh I hear
you met my beautiful wife wait that's it
what I didn't catch you'll have to
excuse her she can have someone over
tempered damn girl oh wow
Santa calls wife mmm-hmm I want to tap
that ass did you see it out Jesus guys
she's sexy
all right let's do the whoop hello man
Shanta COS is doing good man
Oh No we have to leave safar I don't
want to go on without Stefano
yes I lost pity I waited fine
are you at it for a really long time
like two seconds dears Christ alright
you want to try the door opener I throw
you up and then I open the door and
catch you what okay they're in quite
like that
it's okay pity one day you'll get it
don't worry this way oh oh I guess I was
on the Santa's helpers but he's naked
what the [ __ ] where's the father
that what what the ID mr. Sherr got him
good
I got him pretty darn no way all right
oh Jesus Christ what's that thing he
didn't have an autumn I don't dress I'm
so happy I can help Santa out with this
present he even made this room but his
wife I'm not even gonna talk about it I
can tell she's so hot I mean it's not
it's not good to well if the boss has a
hot wife you should probably shouldn't
talk about it I mean it's obvious
alright let's continue far away
I don't trust this place Oh yo yo yo yo
boy hey awesome sir I like it it's cool
all right let's play the piano all right
I'll do this one go do it do it you and
me it's the final all right we showing
the other place fun
how about jingle bells I love that song
all right I'm just gonna put you down
buddy all right there we go
all right jingle bells jingle bells
jingle all the way
take it Stefano oh it's father that's
the ride all right I should probably
shouldn't [ __ ] around Who am I
what why not what do you mean talk [ __ ]
around Baron I I don't understand you
sometimes Billy but it's okay I have a
Santa hey more presents all right it's
gonna make room for the present so
Stefano the naughty list grumped a
barrel and making about a statue I don't
trust that Ruben beef jerky yeah you
catch other the mother be the penis
wheels that spin mm-hmm the North oh I
get it
I'm so [ __ ] all right so yeah they
they don't deserve any presents I'm good
I'm glad so far I mean Santa Claus has
his priorities set straight no friggin
barrels to serve presents no oh ho oh
you're finally here yes Esther and we
shall have some tea yeah I'll be sure to
help you find your way back home
as soon as my slate is ready honey can
you ready the tea
what what on who are you and what have
you done to my wife would you talk about
sugar cake you are not my wife mister
I'm sorry I really can't watch you I'm
such a good voice like now put down that
knife and let's discuss this at man mmm
woman sorry oh no Santa
now don't die on me
the bro killed Santa why would he do
that
Jesus Christ alright let's kill him I'm
not gonna let him give me barrels let's
get the hell of a minute
I don't trust this brave don't look back
but every door God is happy so sexy
that's also many other Christmas Oh
everything I was supposed to survive
that but whatever
hey what is this oh no not again
telepathic naked guys ah alright the
saving McCall says I didn't call that
during Christmas he sees you when you're
sleeping he knows when you're awake he
knows if you be back again so be good
forget this step out I need you all
right we are finally back you are an
idiot beauty all right you have to run
you better put me down here perfect
alright I don't like this we're gonna
see oh oh it's good I wouldn't see him
it's so awesome
Rob panting what are you dying there's
no time for watching
alright we're good oh now what is that
oh it's probably a bug alright that's
finished alright that was
damnation Christmas special amazing well
exactly my feet if I made bike lanes
three thanks a lot for making it for me
deep and profound story lying
interpreter I planted a test again thing
there interval by Kingston oh yeah my
thing
Weehoo the grounds will bring you many
presences I don't know thanks for
watching please leave a like put some a
lot of work and effort into this
[Music]
thanks again some thanks for making it I
guess I don't judge it it was made in a
really short
[Music]
but yeah I wish you all of you bros I'm
Merry Merry Christmas
and you help hope we brothers get a lot
of fresh a lot of media games and I'm
actually going to Italy so I probably
want to upload as many videos and kisses
Christmas you know my room right hope
you understand anyway I will be back
don't worry maybe you can catch up on
some other series I don't know again my
Christmas Happy New Year and all that
kind of stuff I'll see you later all
right
[Music]
organized
step on it she even gave him like a
scarf because it's Chris
I'll SPD I survived